I'm legally really not meant to comment
on the Tinder times I don't even know if
I've told the story
but
Whitney wolf heard the CEO and founder
of bumble Whitney became one of the few
women who can add billionaire to her
title the dating app that puts women in
charge of making the first move making
the first move can change your life but
you have to do it no one can do it for
you which would then become bumble's
entire Mantra I've seen all the things
that Bumble have done over the years and
it's always seems to be original in its
nature it was a lot of these tiny
hacking Concepts that made no sense no
one had ever done these things before
but if you understand what moves and
motivates people then you have this
opportunity to connect with them and so
that's been the superpower of ours over
the years as 31 years old you're the
youngest woman to take a company public
what's the personal toll on you in those
moments it's been pretty dark it's been
pretty heavy
departure from Tinder read to me like it
was horrific and sexist it was Soul
Crush I was being described in all sorts
of ways I had reporters trying to go
through my window and it was really
violating there's a whole Persona that's
been created about me out there in the
world how am I ever going to escape this
I was 24 years old
if I asked your teams must what do you
like as a leader what would they say to
me I don't know we did ask them oh so
Whitney
what is the early context
that I would have to understand about
you and your life to understand you
I think
probably broken gender Dynamics
growing up so I grew up in Salt Lake
City Utah
I don't know if you know much about I
know Salt Lake City Utah yep so it's a
very LDS it was kind of the formal
religious term
um or better known as Mormon place
and my dad is Jewish
and my mother is Catholic so I'm already
total
um anomaly in this place and it's a very
tough Community to fit into when you
don't
look act behave like everybody else or
have the exact same belief systems and
the Mormon faith
and the LDS faith not to generalize but
it's very much a community or at least
it was I was born in 1989 so growing up
back in the 90s it was very much a man's
world
where the man is
the you know the breadwinner or the man
is out mom is at home in an apron and
everyone follows rules lots of rules
very strict rules in fact and I think I
always grew up with a
conflicting set of values to my
community to this ecosystem I was placed
in or was raised in rather and then that
started to come out in relationships so
my first you know real boyfriend that I
ever had it was quite toxic and these
were kind of these undertones of my
entire life that would then set the
stage for my entire career
using that first relationship that first
sort of toxic relationship is an example
of how your belief system at that point
was causing problems
um could you give me some color to what
you mean there yeah it was a it was you
know it was a new experience for me I
was a young young girl at the time and I
think there was this set of behaviors I
was expected to adhere to to be on his
rules his his
um
you know what he believed was right and
it was quite demoralizing frankly and I
don't think at the time I fully
recognized what was taking place until
later in life but it set the stage for
me about unhealthy relationships and I
recognized just how unequal women were
when it came to their romantic
relationship so if you were to fast
forward here I am running this business
where women make the first move which
when I put that into the product in 2014
was
squawk that and eyes were rolled and
people couldn't understand why we would
do such a thing because women aren't
supposed to talk first so if you look at
that moment of a business being born
there's so much more than just a Eureka
thought it's really pent up
years and years of
confusion passion purpose Brewing
to essentially be born into this moment
of bumble were you rebelling at all
against that environment or that belief
system I think there was
two sides of that coin there was the
side that wanted to fit in desperate to
be a part of my community desperate to
be a part of what was around me and to
fit in and to fit the mold because
that's humans humans want to fit into
their environments they want to be
accepted no one wants to be the child
sitting alone at the lunch table this is
what devastates humans to be left out
right so there was a part of me that's
so desperately wanted validation and to
fit and then there was a part of me that
said this is wrong this doesn't feel
right this feels against my
Soul this doesn't feel
like how things should be
and I feel like that's been a theme of
my life there's been Duality on on this
topic in every
every situation I've been in and that's
that's part of navigating it
how do we navigate that Duality because
we all we all experience those
sort of conflicting needs at the same
time often one of them is like an
external one can fly can colliding with
an internal need that's going unmet and
it feels sometimes like we have to
choose as you said like the external
Comfort fitting in or validation versus
like this doesn't feel good to me yeah
inside
I think for me at least
I have to live in a place of
authenticity and I've lived in chapters
of my life that were not authentic that
I knew what I was participating in or
what I was doing didn't feel authentic
to what I really believed in or what I
knew to be right
and genuinely authenticity wins that's
my fundamental belief and I think that
when you follow and Chase that authentic
space
the world opens up for you the world
unlocks
sometimes in the short term when we
especially if we've had a prolonged
period of being inauthentic what we've
done accidentally and inadvertently has
created an environment and a community
and a job and a an environment where
that's built on that in authenticity so
to make the change just to one day be
like you know what today I'm going to be
authentic requires it seems like quite a
lot of short-term loss I expect disprove
of people going
stay stay stay in line stay who we
thought you were you know be the person
that we resonated with even if that was
your inauthentic self
so that like I think I see so many
people kind of contend with that they
want they kind of might know who they
are that voice inside but the apparent
cost of pursuing it
seems circus mom and dad and my
boyfriend and I have to leave the city
and my job and my friendship you know of
course
you have to leave the tribe yeah
it's terrifying terrifying
it's almost
unimaginable for people and
I've been there I felt that feeling
before and I think this is why so many
people
stay in whatever situation they're in
stay in a marriage stay in a business
stay in a church
stay in a team
stay in a you name it this is what
perpetuates the cycle of
of the quest to
fit in versus
just truly being who you really are and
so that age-old saying be yourself it's
harder than it looks it's really hard
and it comes with a lot of risk and it's
scary and it's dangerous and what if I
fail and what if
no one likes me and what if everyone
judges me these are real things but at
the end of the day nothing could be
worse than
having a broken relationship with
yourself right I personally think a
broken relationship with yourself is
more toxic than a pseudo
phony good relationship with a hundred
other people
but it's hard to give ourselves that
love and compassion we're hard on
ourselves the things we say to ourself
is something we would never say to
another ever I mean think about that
rhetoric the internal self-talk
we would never say those things to other
people right and the compliments we pay
others it's very hard to pay ourselves
so when you think about that narrative
how can we expect people to have the
confidence and courage to be authentic
to themselves if they're not even
willing to
accept themselves so I think that's a
big piece of it right and I've watched
over the years women I grew up with in
Salt Lake City just now in their 30s
they're coming out of their cage they're
quite literally coming alive and they're
taking to tick tock into social media
and they're taking to all these
platforms
like a roaring lion saying I'm alive and
I've been hiding and I've been living by
standards and I've been living by rules
and I've been living by X Y and Z and
it's not authentic so at some point it
will burst open you know like that the
truth is the truth does prevail
when you when you were 18 what was
acceptance or success to you if I asked
you were 18 years old what you want to
be post uni when you grow up what would
the answer have been at that point
well the answer of what I really wanted
to be was not what I would have said
because I would have said something to
fit in right that's standard so I think
the young women when I was in college
all wanted to go work for a fashion
brand or get a job at a bank or be
successful and they wanted to get
married
and they wanted to find someone that
they could marry settle down with have
kids with eventually maybe not next year
but that was part of the program right
this dating game exists as college
students and
this is where the undertones of bumble
started to really form because I
remember being in college and
being completely judged and made fun of
by girlfriends of mine if I texted a guy
first I remember I went on a date which
was so out of my character I really
believe it or not being so ingrained in
the dating world I think I've been on
maybe three dates in my life that sounds
weird but I went on a date and then I
texted the guy afterwards and they were
like oh no you have committed a sin a
sin like you should be ashamed of
yourself
it made me cry I felt so embarrassed I
felt so ashamed and I remember thinking
this is wrong what is wrong with you why
why can we not text who wrote these
rules what are these rules these rules
are ridiculous so this this desire to
break the rules change the rules rewrite
the rules with something I inherently
felt deep down but everybody's felt that
you felt that everybody has felt that
it's just who chooses to go and actually
act on it is the difference
I was I was thinking then when you when
you talked about
um being 18 and having this kind of sort
of social expectation of what success
would look like and then having a family
was the orientation of a lot of young
women at that point do you think there
are
any gender differences that are innate
to us that have
a bearing on the path or the way that we
show up that are innate I.E not social
constructs but do you think there's
anything in us as as men and women that
makes us want different things from
birth innately
you know it's a good question and I have
two little boys right now
and I think a lot of this is imposed on
us as a society
I really do I think the toys we buy our
children and the clothes we put on our
children and the shows we show our
children you have to really ask yourself
is this not truly forming what they're
interested in and what they care about
and what their Ambitions are
I do believe that
there may be something and I see this in
men too
folks that genuinely want to have a
family and have children and be part of
that type of a life and then folks that
just genuinely don't but I don't really
see it with I don't think it's a gender
thing I really think that these are just
a personal soul level thing but I think
Society comes in and puts bows on it or
puts trucks on it and says here's your
path so it's it's interesting now
raising kids seeing if I really believe
this nature versus nurture thing and I
think there's components to it but I
think it's definitely more
imposed Upon Us by others around this
morning I was watching my son read a
book at breakfast I don't know where he
found the book I think it was something
he found at the restaurant but I opened
it and it was a picture of a pig family
in a little house and you could see
everything in all the different rooms
and Daddy was upstairs in the bathroom
combing his hair in a suit and the pig
mom was in the it's like the pig family
the piggy mom was in the kitchen in a
pink dress with an apron cooking eggs
and I was just thinking to myself here
is a almost three-year-old these are the
books they're reading and it says
where's Daddy and where's Mommy so we
have to imagine that we we do some of
this to the to the kids around us
you burn the book I took a picture of it
and raved about raged about it at work
for about three hours and we will not be
reading the book again
what was your normal education
I say what was your in terms of
University or anything like that what
did you study yeah so
um I went to college in Texas
and I really wanted to go into marketing
and I wanted to go into advertising and
marketing which is funny because now
somehow I've ended up there a little bit
and I sat down for the test and
completely failed it I could not answer
any of the questions it was so confusing
to me it was all about
you know return on investment and
television views and it was super not to
be disrespectful but super boring I was
like um this is probably not for me but
anyway I did not get it accepted so I
studied
um International Studies
and that was just this huge mix of
big people problems you know
globalization
anthropology women's studies gender
studies
um international relations I mean it was
really
fascinating and that was the best
marketing degree I could have ever
gotten because it's the study of people
why do people do what they do
and if you look at the business I'm in
I'm quite literally immersed all day
long into why do people date who they
date why do they want what they want how
do they behave why do they get
aggressive what causes aggression what
causes online abuse where is this
stemming from and this stuff is really
interesting so I'd say my education
really did help me
connect those dots
and as you leave that that degree
that gap between like the Working World
and leaving University College
what was that Gap and how what were you
thinking in that moment where were you
heading what were you applying for where
were you
um seeking the next chapter of your life
so I really wanted to be a Travel
Photographer like a photojournalist
and I had no training in that obviously
but I was just obsessed with the idea
and it's actually funny at the Bumble
office right now we have this photo of
this incredible woman that I met in
Burma and she is holding a bumble
lighter and it's my
never made it to Nat Geo moment
that was my dream I wanted to be a Nat
Geo photographer and so I went traveling
through Southeast Asia
and took a lot of photos and I remember
on my travels thinking gosh there's such
a disconnect for someone trying to
explore a new country place it's only
TripAdvisor and if you follow
TripAdvisor you end up eating a
hamburger in Laos at some version of a
hard rock right and this is not really
the experience I thought why can't I get
to know a local I want to ride around on
the back of a moped and Laos and I want
to go understand what do they do here
like where do the 18 year olds go what
what what was their life like what does
their day look like and I thought why is
there not an app that does this why is
there not something on my phone that can
put me in touch with these people but
then of course that idea fell by the
wayside went into you know the back of
my brain somewhere and by chance one day
would end up in this wild world of
connecting people on the internet so
some of these things were already
brewing and already starting to Bubble
Up in ways that wouldn't totally expose
themselves yet by chance
you ended up in this weird world of
Connecting People what was that chance
so the chance was
that I went to a dinner in Los Angeles
one night with one of my very dear
friends and she had been friendly with a
couple of these These Guys in LA and we
all ended up at dinner because
I didn't end up driving back to my mom's
house that night it got too dark and it
was quite a long drive so we all had
dinner and I was staying at her house
and one of the guys at dinner was the
general manager of this incubator and
was telling me all about this incubator
and here I was a 22 year old just barely
22 if that even two-year-old woman that
needed a job I needed to make money I
needed to find my way in the world and
I'd just been kind of adventuring and
you know seeing the world and exploring
and taking this
very you know
risky path of not going straight into a
career and going to travel and going to
see the world and find my passion and he
said well maybe you could take a
marketing job and I said okay I'll try I
mean I'll call you tomorrow and he's
like okay probably thought I'd never
call and I did long story short that
incubator would be the incubator where
we ended up launching Tinder so it was
um
by happen stance that that connection
happened but I think it was about taking
advantage of an opportunity right seeing
an opportunity and
it didn't feel perfect and I think this
is a good lesson for people is
the way it was described to me at that
dinner
people think oh well she got so lucky
she you know she met the so-and-so of
so-and-so that's not what it was like
this that concept of Tinder was never
mentioned it was never called Tinder at
the time and it was a totally different
opportunity but it was putting my foot
in the door of something that would then
turn into something else and something
else and I think
so many people wait around for the most
perfect headline when it comes to an
opportunity that they can't really see
or read between the lines and everybody
has that potential everybody can do that
they just have to be willing to say well
this is a stepping stone or this is a
door that I could bust open right and I
think
that's kind of how I've tried to
approach most things in my career
it's so true it's you know that moment
there there's so many other outcomes
that could have happened from a dinner
um namely one of them is you just don't
call the person back I mean the amount
of times in my life someone's giving me
their number and said call me and I just
haven't called back most 99 it's like
all of us do that yeah yeah but there's
a philosophy of like leaning into stuff
especially when you're young just like
leaning in regardless of certainties
you've just got a chance yeah and people
have a I see this in people I'm sure you
have as well where people have a
tendency to be like lean in people or
kind of just lean out people even when
the world is changing crypto a Bitcoin
blockchain all these things matter
typically people lean in or lean out
yeah and um I think people that lean in
are the ones that end up creating
opportunity which looks like like in
hindsight yeah I agree with you
and being brave enough to just say even
if it doesn't work out at least I
explored it right I think people
what I've seen and it's something that
I'm guilty of as well in my life is
it's a risk and we have to be willing to
get excited about risk instead of being
afraid of it
um it's the uncertainty though isn't it
how good are you at dealing with
uncertainty without how how guaranteed
do you need the outcome to be before you
take a step right
and for me not very guaranteed
personally because
it's like what do you have to lose right
are is are you creating risk for
yourself not really but I do think that
it's scary to pick up the phone and make
that first move right which would then
become bumble's entire Mantra and
tagline and product and everything but
making the first move and taking that
first step can change your life
but you have to do it no one no one can
do it for you and I learned that the
hard way I I had very little support
along the way in terms of Advocates or
Community you know I had a handful of
people I could call upon but candidly
even when I was starting Bumble all of
my confidants with the exception of a
couple were like no don't do this why
why would you expose yourself to this
what's the point that won't work there's
already dating apps They're Gonna Eat
You Alive
and you can get bogged down in that you
know it's really it's easy to drown in
that noise
in those in those early years of Tinder
I remember being told the story maybe 10
years ago in San Francisco when I was
working there with um a guy called
Michael Birch it was the old Bebo
founder you'll know Bibo Bebo the old
social oh no it didn't go to the US it
was just a production I remember that it
was like Facebook here before before
Facebook okay cool
um and he in his little sort of
incubator that I was in when I was 20
they were telling me the bump the Tinder
story of how you went to a fraternity
for people that don't know what
fraternity is what's a fraternity uh so
I guess in the UK it would be like
college clubs maybe do they have like
members clubs or something like that so
basically sororities and fraternities
and sororities are a house of women and
fraternities are a house of men and
there's different names so they all have
these Greek names right so for example
the one I joined was Kappa Kappa Gamma
you could have
um try Delta there's all sorts of them
and essentially a lot of college
students
they do something called Rush where they
rush and they go house to house and they
meet all the women or all the men and
then they basically pref they put in the
name of the one they would really love
to be a part of and then they see who
accepted them back it's been criticized
up and down and there's a lot of things
that are not you know spectacular about
it but this is a way a lot of people
find friendship and Community it's it's
a community gathering for their college
campus so with Tinder I essentially went
back to my alma mater at SMU I just
graduated so a lot of my best friends
were still in school so I got access to
the campus
and I would start at the sororities and
then go to the fraternity so I'd
essentially have all the young women
download it and then run to the
fraternity and then they would download
it and then everyone would start
connecting so you know is that good is
that bad how do you want to
chop that up 10 years later who knows
but that's the reality and you know
can't escape the truth but so so you
heard about this way back when I heard
about this 10 years ago because we were
building community center caps we're
building something called blab which
resembles what Clubhouse is now
um and when we were talking about the
marketing strategy Tinder kept coming up
and Sean Perry who's now who when the
company got acquired by Amazon in the
end twitch um who owned Amazon other way
around Amazon in touch
um
but yeah that was the that was the
thesis it was like should we go to
fraternities and go get you know and to
try and build that sort of
isolated tight Community to try and get
product Market fit yeah because Network
effects really really matter and
especially in the dating game the most
important yeah that's why there's only a
handful of dating apps that have ever
survived I mean at least during my time
doing this which is almost a decade now
but what's interesting is there's such a
not to not to say only I could do this
or only somebody else could do this but
there was a superpower in the timing of
it all because I just graduated
and I I knew all of these people so
if some random startup founder knocks on
a sorority door the police are coming
you know like you can't you can't do
that so I felt like I had this Insider
hook right because I was technically an
extension of that by proxy because I had
just been on the college campus and all
my girlfriends were still there so they
were part of these sororities and all my
guy friends were there they were part of
these fraternities so I'll never forget
I took the photo of one of my guy
friends back then who was you know all
the young women had Mega crush on on him
and then I took the photo of my best
friend
um Danielle who was very well liked on
campus and I went into Danny's
journalism class because she was still a
student and I basically snuck into her
journalism class and used Photoshop and
I took the Tinder screens and I put the
guy's face on one and her face on the
other and said find out who likes you on
campus and then I saved it to a file
because this is the olden days at this
point and I went to FedEx which is like
the office supply store across the
street and I printed a thousand copies
and I quite literally handed different
students on campus twenty dollars to go
distribute them under dorm doors and put
them on windshields and to put them you
know in their different Social Clubs and
to essentially distribute these flyers
everywhere
so this entire campus and now in
hindsight it's probably not great it's
littering there's all sorts of bad
things involved with it but like I'm
just telling you a story so
um
yeah basically that was that was just
one of the tactics I I used to go and
put it all over campus and then I had a
few t-shirts printed up that said don't
ask for my number find me on Tinder and
I had my girlfriends wear the t-shirts
and we went to the bar and so I gave
them you know a couple hundred bucks
and they would go around and buy drinks
and then when people would ask for their
number they'd essentially say you have
to download Tinder so it was a lot of
these tiny hacking Concepts that made no
sense no one had ever done these things
before I had no Playbook it wasn't like
you know I was reading some manual to
marketing it was just what felt
around me it was it was just bringing
the real life dating experience to life
through through an app
um marketing there's like so many
important messages of marketing there I
mean the first one that you said was was
that you were the customer you were so
close to the customer that you
understood them I mean even you said um
about how for another startup had come
and knocked on the sorority well they
wouldn't even know which door to knock
on for a star that's true right it would
have knocked on the wrong door got the
wrong people
um and they wouldn't have understood
those people their motivation so like
really you being the customer I think is
such a key thing and then the second
thing you said about like if I'd read a
marketing book
um and you were kind of just doing it
based on intuition
I've I've seen over and over again from
speaking to really successful CEOs and
Founders how important naivet he was
like not knowing so important just
following your gut yeah because then you
that's like first print that's creating
something from first principles as
opposed to Convention that's real
Innovation right like and it creates
solutions that are more suited for today
and for the challenge that you're
solving which no one has ever had the
challenge of solving right on that date
right right
um but naivety you know this is this is
sometimes why I think some of the best
Founders don't come from like business
school or from marketing School the best
marketeers aren't marketing graduates
because naivety is such a superpower
it's a superpower and
following
your instinct
and if you understand
what moves people and what motivates
people then you have this opportunity to
connect with them on a real level I mean
we've done things that are ridiculous so
I remember
we would make these signs that said they
had the big X's like no you know like
you're not allowed to and they said no
Facebook no Instagram no Snapchat no
bumble
this was like week three of bumble or
something some ridiculous early maybe
first year I can't remember at this
point and we would post those all over
the universities so there was this
Association where it was like wait I
can't do the things I really want to do
I want to sit in class and Snapchat I
want to sit in class and Instagram what
the hell is Bumble and so we were
essentially seeding this psychological
curiosity and then we were actually
sending
young women wearing Bumble shirts into
classes 10 or 15 minutes late
interrupting a class of 300 people and
saying oh sorry wrong room but
everyone's looking at this young woman
and or a young man whoever it was
wearing a bumble t-shirt so we were
seating curiosity in this like why is
Bumble everywhere type of thing and so
you know a lot of people think oh well I
can just go start a an app and I'll just
buy some you know Instagram ads and I'll
just be successful but if people only
knew the fraction
of the
insane everyday little hacks that you
know I did and our team did to bring
this to life we were the first people
certainly the first tech brand to do
humor accounts to pay for the humor
memes do you remember the humor means
well we ran a bit of 100 million
followers on Meme accounts so yeah so
you know all about this but like we were
way back years and years ago I remember
reaching out to I can't remember what it
was one of these meme accounts and
they're like wait you want to pay us to
I'm confused how does that work and
we're like okay here's the deal we'll
give you 100 bucks or whatever it was we
turn around a year later that same
account is charging a hundred thousand
dollars a post so we there's also
something about luck and timing being
just right before something you know and
if you look at Bumble we were also
beating the woman drum the the this this
drum of we need to advocate for women
beating this drama of let's
put women first let's let's Elevate
women women are not equal in their
relationships women are not being
treated respectfully women are being
abused on the internet women are not
being treated right we were saying this
in 2014 and then me too would come a
couple of years later so I think we've
we've been lucky as a business
to basically
be right before the wave and then we've
been able to be a part of that wave
versus chasing a wave and so many people
chase a wife so many people chase away
if they look around them like well
what's cool how do I chase that and I
feel like we've always had the good
fortune or whatever you want to call it
um
sure inspiration to go first
and so that's been maybe a superpower of
ours over the years because you're
making those decisions it's so clear to
me that you're making those decisions
from original thought and from like what
I think Elon calls like first principles
as in what do we know is true
and create a solution from that versus
how is it done how's it been done before
and that like and even you being early
to the meme account things just for
context
um
we were probably like probably probably
maybe one of the first companies in the
world I'd say to to do the meme thing
that's really like how my business began
we had like 100 million followers on
these meme accounts that became this big
social media business this big Media
company and it can e-com and then it
went public but it started with meme
accounts this is how I met
I think you're original investors hi
Matt Purdue so I remember speaking to
having these long conversations with
them in London about we'll make you
Trend number one on Twitter we'll do a
Thunderclap or they can't say at the
same like but for you to have been one
of the brands that was leaning into that
do you know what their brands had no and
to your point yes the meme accounts were
there you were pioneering all of that
but I don't know if you experienced this
Brands did not see their place there and
the brands that did that I had seen had
been like by my bracelet or by my
fashion company you know it was
something very consumer Centric which
made sense but it wasn't the download my
app yeah and that was such a different
way of promoting something even for the
app world it was it was so out of bounds
for the app space because the app space
used traditional app space yeah
acquisition strategies you're right it
wasn't it wasn't and the reason why we
managed to get so many followers is
because
um people didn't value those accounts so
I remember buying beef at motivation
which had about 10 million I'll say
followers
um love food which had about seven
million followers and beef at motivation
on Twitter which had two million
followers on Twitter
um just those just that 20 million
followers cost me about 10 grand oh God
imagine it's like really good real
estate it's like buying a house and it's
a crazy part of London a thousand years
ago and then all the other accounts were
free because unbelievable I I offered
the people jobs that random you'll have
a proper job you get paid loads I know
your mum doesn't think it's a job I
think it's a job I see you I validate
you
people like oh you're exploiting well
nobody valued it back then and then they
eventually did value those social media
accounts and what you're talking about
the whole you know it was attention it
was it was attention it was eyeballs and
from a first principles perspective you
go well we want attention and eyeballs
they are here I don't care if it's safe
cool or the dumb thing that's where
we're gonna go and I saw Bumble doing
that and and I've seen all the things
that Bumble have done over the years and
it's always seems to be original in its
nature it feels that way it feels like
someone has had an original thought
today about how to solve a problem and
not just they're not just focused on
showing what Bumble is
that that communicating how you should
feel about Bumble that was always the
goal yeah and I think there was a lot of
people that thought it was ridiculous
early on they're like why are you doing
a campaign that has nothing to do with
dating you know we did this huge
campaign where our team
put together this
you know huge push on be the CEO your
parents always wanted you to marry and
then in parentheses it said and then
find someone you actually like for want
to date and
I remember a lot of people being like
we're not going to do this this there's
no Roi here what's the ROI there's no
call to action there's no download in
the App Store
and
what was fascinating was it built this
wild following of our brand so people
that would never have downloaded a
dating app are now wearing our hat now
their mother is carrying around a bumble
tote because they're proud of the brand
and they are you know it created this
untangible feeling right this magic and
there was a sentiment that was more
powerful than any you know Roi campaign
you could do on any other channel and so
I feel like
for me I always wanted Bumble to be more
than just an app in your pocket I want
it to be something that gave you a
feeling and a good feeling not a bad one
because so many of these products give
us bad feelings and they make us feel
uninspired and they make us feel lonely
they make us feel broken they make us
feel exhausted and I wanted us to do
something different and our team wanted
us to do something different we had such
a passionate team we still have an
incredibly passionate team but that
early community of our team is really
what made this company so magical right
it was that genuine purpose and buy-in
and candidly naivete our team was young
our team was separated from a lot of our
infrastructure meaning like a lot of the
more technical stuff was isolated from
the marketing stuff and I've been
criticized over the years by the you
know the tech Publications and the tech
this and the tech that and whatever I
don't really care the point is it's been
like well this isn't this isn't how
Silicon Valley does it we're the
engineers and why are this and why
aren't you sitting with the engineers
and there was a method to the madness it
was
let's let this team go out and paint the
town yellow
and do it with no interruption no
distraction and then let's let our
fantastic infrastructure team really
solve big problems through Tech while
these two heart and brain can operate
together right and I had never really
been done before in this like
traditional Silicon Valley world
my first startup experience is not like
my second startup experience you learn
all the lessons you learn well you
hopefully learn the lessons I think I've
learned hopefully learned some of them
um but your first startup experience at
Tinder this is when you know because
especially when it's moving at the speed
of light
you know I mean my startup didn't move
at the speed of light quite like Tinder
did but still absolutely the speed of
light Tinder moved at and there's that
culture out in San Francisco about you
know move fast and break things which is
I think Facebook popularized I think
that was their slogan but everyone kind
of has adopted that mindset of just go
[ __ ] lightning fast
and figure it out later fix it while
it's fix it while we're falling kind of
thing
um talk to me about that talk to me
about the the cost of that what it
taught you and really give me a picture
of what it was like in those early
rocket ship days
well you know I think
it was so new to everyone involved no
one
no one really
understood
what the next day held this was such a
different time also you know Instagram
had just had its big sale now in
retrospect not such a big sale but at
the time remarkable right
um still remarkable regardless and it
was just such a new environment Tech was
still relatively niche mobile was very
Niche right it was not super mainstream
apps were kind of hitting the scene but
not like where we are today there's an
app for this after that and
we were this tight tribe of people that
really probably had not much to do with
each other outside of this but
it became this 24 7 unit and we were
just fighting every day to keep it going
I mean our Blood Sweat and Tears went
into this business right so when I left
it was completely devastating because I
wasn't just leaving this rocket ship of
a business that's one thing
but I've just been essentially you know
one day in a 24 7 environment with the
same people for more than two years to
the next day never seeing any of them
ever again
and in the middle of that ending up on
the front page of all sorts of magazines
and newspapers because of the
Narrative of the ending right and it was
it was extremely traumatic extremely I
was
I think I was stuck in fight or flight
mode for years
um because you know that was all I knew
for years and it had been such a
zero to a hundred experience as you know
when you're in these startups it's
they're almost their own I'm definitely
not accusing the company of making this
but they become their own little Cults
and it's really hard to
go from that one day to not that the
next day and then to go
end up launching
a woman version to some degree within
six months of leaving
so if you can just try to imagine what
every day looked like to both mourn and
grieve my exit from Tinder
and deal with all the
logistical pieces of it
and the media pieces of it which were
coming at me I had reporters trying to
go through my window at my little
apartment in Beverly Hills from some rag
magazine I mean this is just crazy for
me I was a nobody I mean I'm still
technically a nobody but it's not like I
was on some reality show and I became
popular overnight like this was
traumatizing to me
and
you know it's funny like the land of
everyone trying to be famous I was
probably maybe one of the only people
not at that point right so it was very
crazy to just all of a sudden in a very
scandalous way by the way I was
described in the media
I was literally painted as this like
scandalous Gone Girl of the tech world
and it was Soul crushing because it's
not who I was it's not who I am
so I was watching this narrative unfold
about me and I was in these Twitter
discussions with all the most important
people in the tech world and it was just
crazy I was just watching this narrative
unfold about this person that wasn't me
and then I'm turning around
in the same breath
meeting up with Andre and
then I'm you know
even before that trying to start mayor C
this compliments oriented Kinder social
network which then I meet up with Andre
and one thing leads to another and now
Bumble is my new path and now we're
starting Bumble and this is all going on
it was a whirlwind
a whirlwind
what is what is the the context you're
able to share about why they were
writing those headlines about you and
why you are
ostracized from your as you've described
it something that felt a little bit like
a cult which is actually a good
description of how all my companies have
pretty much started it feels like a 24
7. does it feel that way come on we're
going to take over the world is that
kind of it's I mean it's crazy yeah I
mean like the way people speak about
what you're going to do I mean they're
such big ideas and there's such like
passionate ideas and then you go from
real world which is so mundane right
it's like quite boring out there in the
real world to this like super like high
energy
you know there's you know gonna be a
disaster if we don't do this in the next
five minutes this is crashing that's
crashing this metric's up this metric's
off one day you're booming the next day
you're crying I mean the adrenaline you
know what I'm talking about the ups and
the downs and the hard work that goes
into it and the skipping meals and the
no sleep and everything feels
potentially fatal as well at that point
isn't it fatal and the other thing that
is interesting is you
can't connect with everybody else the
way you used to because they're they
can't quote unquote get it they don't
get it you know so it's like trying to
like have a Sunday afternoon meal with
your family or your friends during that
you're like I can't like we don't even
speak the same language anymore so I'll
just avoid them yeah
you have no idea what's going on so
which in hindsight I think I lived in
that mindset for years between Tinder
and Bumble I mean kind of coming up for
air now and having time to breathe and
think like that's a
I'm sure a lot of people that have built
companies feel this way though I'm sure
you feel this way where you're like whoa
I isolated myself from a lot of
important relationships
that there's regret to that at some
point do you ever feel that way 100 I
was incredibly lonely I didn't speak to
my family didn't really see them for
many many years and I thought that
I thought that something mattered much
more and eventually even if I used to
think I was immune but eventually your
body will remind you that you are a
human too and you have needs and you
need to be unmet and the signal will
come in many ways I hear the signal
sometimes come for people that have
panic attacks they'll feel a growing
sense of loneliness their health will
give out I've had said examples where
the body has just shut down yeah and
I've gone through that yeah as you know
Intel are now one of the sponsors of
this podcast and I'm here to tell you
about one of the latest Intel Evo
designs I've been recently using this
laptop and honestly I've been blown away
by how user-friendly it is to use Intel
has spent thousands of hours studying
the way people use their laptops and
then collaborating with leading PC
makers to co-engineer optimize and test
these laptops to create the Intel Evo
platform which delivers the ultimate
mobile experience laptop design has only
received the Intel Evo badge after
they've been rigorously tested to pass
Intel's own strict requirements and
deliver an ideal combination of features
such as long lasting fast charging
battery Wi-Fi connectivity standards and
a super slim design the result is a
premium laptop that delivers an ideal
combination of features in the coming
weeks I'm going to break down exactly
what features you get when you buy an
Intel Evo certified laptop and how
they've made my life on the go 10 times
easier to find out more about the Intel
Evo platform go to intel.co.uk Evo and
let me know how you get on this episode
is brought to you by Mercedes-Benz who
recent me got in touch to support the
diver CEO thank you I'm a huge fan of
their cars in fact I have one of my own
which is like an office on Wheels and
they have an exciting wide range of cars
that I'd love to tell you about the
Mercedes EQ is the luxury electric range
of Mercedes-Benz and it is available
across many models from the SUVs to the
saloons meaning they're ideal for all
business needs the Innovative Next
Generation technology found in all
Mercedes EQ cars is really Paving the
way for the electric car industry to
make your electric car switch so much
easier Mercedes-Benz has a service
called Mercedes me charge it's a
subscription which provides you with
access to a wide network of charging
stations across the entirety of the UK
the app shows you the precise location
and current availability and price at
the selected charging station of your
choice and this enables businesses to
effectively plan their route ahead of
their Journey you can search
Mercedes-Benz Fleet today to discover
how the Mercedes EQ car range can help
your business get ahead and if you
already drive a Mercedes EQ let me know
how you find it I read that your
departure from Tinder was um ominous to
say the least in fact that's actually
the word that's written in my notes in
2014 and in the early days of the
Foundation the founding of Tinder you'd
had a relationship with somebody that
relationship had ended you were then
treated in a pretty horrendous way from
everything that I read online
um threatened multiple times people
saying that they would they would fire
you for things they didn't have a
justification to fire you for
um sort of patronizing condescending
Behavior to the fact that you were a
young female co-founder and and how they
would take that co-founder title from
you
um it's actually really hard for me to
read actually just from it kind of makes
me a bit
feel a sense of Injustice in my core
um you were called Annoying and dramatic
at certain times when you raised certain
concerns
and as a result
um you you know you were
you ended up leaving the company you're
fired I read you're fired from the
company
which is even worse when you raise
certain concerns you then filed a
lawsuit
um which went on and there was certain
actions taken and there was a reported
settlement reached at one point but
overall your treatment while you were at
Tinder specifically from Men
read to me like it was allegedly
horrific and unfair and sexist
um and then upon leaving Tinder
there's this huge wave of press who are
mischaracterizing you what happened and
you fall into this situation where
you've been in this cult we'll call it
cult because that's how it often feels
to both of us for so long you come out
of that and you're greeted with this
wall of like mischaracterization attacks
um from all sides and you're kind of out
on your own then that's the moment where
you're ostracized from the tribe
um and you're dealing with this wave of
negativity
yeah so you know I'm legally really not
meant to comment on the Tinder times but
what I will say is
I was literally
broken
during that chapter where I was waking
up to headlines about myself like you
said I was being described in all sorts
of ways and people were calling my
you know my uncle and my ex-boyfriend I
mean it was this digging weird
investigation into my life and all I
wanted was to just do my job right and
so
it was a very dark toxic moment and I
felt
so alone
and I felt so unsupported because this
was before me too this is before time's
up any woman that said anything out of
line was called names and this was still
during a chapter even in modern land
that
was
not really pro-women and so no matter
what I said or did I wasn't going to be
able to get through there was judgment I
had friends from college didn't want to
talk to me anymore they were like oh
this this feels this feels icky I don't
um This Isn't that cool you know like
all I was ostracized I was just I had a
Scarlet Letter
and that was such a devastating feeling
because let's just remember it was just
a young professional I was 24 years old
and I've been working my tail off
for two plus years I had
obviously Teamwork Makes the Dream Work
I still fundamentally believe that but I
had played my role and an important one
right to get the company to where it was
so to be called all these names and to
be
basically just written off by Twitter
and the random media and the random
everyone
and I have big respect for media and I'm
not criticizing them I'm just saying
this was the narrative at the time so it
was really hard I was super depressed I
was paranoid
I was actually don't think I left the
house for like uh three weeks at one
point I'll never forget Actually I don't
even know if I've told the story maybe I
have but when I was launching Bumble
again because you have to remember
Bumble launched within six months of my
departure
so not the departure itself but six
months from kind of
when the legal pieces
were put to bed
that was August I want to say August 3rd
December 1st Bumble is live in the App
Store
you know how much work goes in to
launching something it's a 24-hour job I
had another 24-hour job of grieving and
being in fight or flight defense mode of
whatever Twitter was coming after me
with and it was really hard so I think
there was a chapter where I didn't leave
the house for several weeks and when I
was launching Bumble um
I think it was Business Insider I can't
remember who they were doing a piece on
Bumble and they needed a picture of me
and I was like well I'm not taking any
pictures there's no way I'm in
sweatpants and UGGs I'm not leaving this
house so I went outside in my front yard
and swept pants and UGGs with a sweater
on and did like a half fake smile and
had someone take a picture on some
camera I had at home that I had you know
used way back when when I wanted to be a
travel journalist and use that and I
just had to peel myself back up I just
had to peel myself off the ground and I
was lucky to have a couple really strong
people in my life that had my back like
my now husband like Andre
um there were a couple people that were
like I don't care what people say about
you I don't care
we believe in you we know that you're
capable we know you're smart we know
that you can do this again so you need
to go chase your dreams you're not done
and you know I'd very soon after leaving
Tinder
in this moment of Despair and drinking
too much not like socially like at home
like very depressed trying to numb
myself in any way I could
um I had this moment where I was like I
have to solve this part of my psyche is
find a problem and solve it it could be
anything micro anything it's it's just
part of the way my brain works and the
being attacked on the internet felt like
such a big problem to me and I felt like
this was something so many people were
going through so many young girls in
particular were going through being
bullied and I thought to myself I'm an
adult like I can get in a car and I can
drive to a grocery store and I can do
all these things these young women are
trapped at home after school often in
bad circumstances at home and they're
being abused by people they actually
know how horrible would that be I'm
getting attacked by strangers they're
getting attacked by friends at school
and strangers not really
in the sense of stranger to us like
proxy strangers right friends of friends
and I was like I have to fix this I have
to fix this it's my duty on Earth to fix
this
so I started quite literally with a
pencil and a pen I still have the early
drawings sketching out a new Social
Network
it was called mercy and the only
currency and the only way to communicate
with compliments so instead of saying
you know you're stupid or you don't look
good or you're this or body shaming or
that or even hey you're so skinny
something that is negative even though
it feels positive
I wanted it just to be compliments and
so it was essentially supposed to be the
girl's dressing room the girl's bathroom
when when young women go out to
nightclubs there's this saying that
young women are so nice to each other in
the bathroom at a nightclub and I wanted
to bring that to life so I started
sketching that out to basically rebuild
myself and long story short
um
eventually Bumble would become what it
was you know I met Andre and then I mean
I had known him but I reconnect with
Andre
one thing led to the next and Bumble was
born so I think what people don't
realize they've I've had a lot of people
that maybe I went to college with
they're like oh my God you've had such a
good career you're so lucky you're so
successful I'm like um it's been pretty
dark it's been pretty heavy
mark
is there a because I reflect on my
darkest times and I can typically
typically remember a worse day a day
when
you know I just couldn't see the light
at the end of the tunnel what was your
darkest day throughout that period
I've several that are pretty visceral
and memorable
but one that I think maybe is something
people can actually tangibly like put
themselves into this moment
um
I mean you can imagine there's lots of
tough moments along the way but one was
we had worked so hard to build Bumble in
stealth mode starting from about
August through call it November so head
down four or five months of just like 24
hours a day back into the you know the
grind
and
it was really important to me not to
attach my name to it I was so scared of
putting my name on it I didn't want to
muddy it I was like you know I'm in the
media as this like
scandalous person right now and I don't
I don't want to be known for I don't
want I don't want this to be about me I
want this to be about what the product
is and what the mission is I want women
to go first in their relationships I
want women to be empowered and I
remember we had worked so hard to keep
my name out of it I
had like a pseudo email that I was using
to reach out to certain people that I
thought could
you know maybe leak that this was
happening and we were going to launch in
mid-December they'd gone on this
investigative adventure of sorts of
following all my early employees and
ambassadors and they were going through
all the images and piecing together this
story about this new product that was
launching
and the headline
said
something along the lines maybe not
verbatim but it was really hurtful it
was like basically I'm summarizing how I
internalized it surprise surprise like
the scorned woman from Tinder launches
her own dating app but women go first
and oh I hear she really likes bees
she's called a bumble like it was so
hurtful and I just sobbed and I sobbed
because there had been so much work that
went into coming back rising from the
ashes and pulling myself back up
and to keep it in this kind of self
position away from me and not make it
about that not make it about that you
know I women have a
and everyone every gender we all have an
opportunity and a I believe a human
right to start over
we all have the right to start over none
of us should be held
Hostage to
a certain chapter in our lives or a
certain thing in our lives like we
should all be able to get back up right
if we're still breathing you have that
right and that felt like my right to
starting over on my own terms was taken
from me and it was really violating so
in my typical fashion I cried about it
for a while and then I pivoted so I
called my early team I said we have a we
have a problem
whoever it was has basically
um
leaked this information which is their
job I you know I don't hold them again
it's not their fault but they basically
have have told everybody that we're
doing this app and that it's coming out
and that I'm behind it but they're kind
of missing the point of what the product
really is
um I think they're misunderstanding why
we're starting this I think for them it
read more of like in a Revenge novel
right
which was not the case it was about
Mercy then evolving into a positive
dating space
so I said okay
um you're all jumping out of an airplane
tomorrow and they're like what do you
mean enjoying up an airplane tomorrow
and I said you have to explain that it's
just not that scary to talk first on a
nap as a woman like if if a woman can
jump out of an airplane they can
certainly send the first message and so
we just pivoted and we went and filmed
this little launch video of literally my
first three employees jumping out of an
airplane and the whole tagline was
um it was something along the lines of
like if we can jump out of an airplane
you can send the first text and that was
kind of how we reframed the discussion
and took you know took control of the
narrative that point about your right to
kind of reinvent yourself or not be
defined by a previous chapter I think is
so important it's also why you know I've
got to be honest like I don't I don't
love talking about it like the Tinder
stuff because it it's it's a it's a step
in your journey it's important
contextual stuff yeah of course you know
it's it's inspired you in in many ways
in terms of your mission and your vision
and your and all of those things but
um I'm glad we could fill that context I
when I asked the um the question about
your your hardest your hardest moment
the darkest times
I was reflecting on some of the quotes
I'd read about when you were in that
moment feeling like maybe life wasn't
worth living anymore yeah and that kind
of thing
and it's hot it's hard to um I think for
a lot of people I hope it's hard for
them to understand that mindset like
getting to that place I hope it's hard
for them to understand I Hope they've
never had to experience it
but for someone that has what what is
that like are those are those words real
that that that Prospect of like maybe
maybe life would be better without me in
it I most certainly felt that way at
times for sure leaving
when I was
going through that chapter I most
certainly had moments where I thought
well this is it I mean what what now I
there's a whole Persona that's been
created about me out there in the world
how am I ever going to escape this I'm
going to be suffocated by
a definition a group of strangers have
assigned to me and my tribe is gone
I'm gone I everything I can identify
with this
you know the startup world can feel like
a cult at times right and so
that all felt gone and I told you
earlier you disassociate from a lot of
the life you once had
friends family you lose
connection with them when you're trying
to build something right and so when you
leave that thing you're building it's
not like okay well let me just go home
to Grandma's house
that doesn't feel like an option
you don't feel like you can relate to
anyone anymore and I just did not
understand what the point was anymore
but it was right in that moment
literally I want to say like that was
the same same piece of the same storm
of feeling such a deep pain
in such a deep problem which the problem
to me was toxic internet and how toxic
it could be and how detrimental it could
be for your mental health
that a solution came
and so I really channeled that dark dark
dark
loathing and pain and instead of
drowning in it
I kind of started swimming as fast as I
could
for for air and my air was go rebuild
yourself right and so
I think that that that's
ultimately the way I was able to reframe
that and
I think the internet can make you feel
very alone and very isolated and very
lonely and we start believing it as our
reality right what the internet says is
not really what's in the park across the
street and I think that's important for
people to hear is that whatever you're
feeling based on what people are saying
on the Internet or whatever you've read
turn off the phone for a little bit and
go outside right because I didn't do
that in that moment and I think we have
to realize that it's not always our
reality
very powerful this leads to Bumble which
is
um which was a game changer in its
industry it was the first of its kind it
was the first of its kind in many
respects including just the look and
feel and messaging that's really you
know as a marketeer that's the thing I I
always respected I mean I really
respected the um the point of women
getting to go first because I'd never
seen that before I've never seen that
done in the way that it's done on Bumble
but from a marketing marketeer's mindset
I really respected how bold how clear
how much Bumble were willing to position
themselves as the antithesis the the
opposite of everything else that existed
it was really willing to take to bring A
New Concept and a new idea to the market
um when you look back at the earliest
days of bumble like the first year two
years of bumble now with the hindsight
of knowing how things all how the dots
connected why did you win
I'm not sure did we win
listen how many customers did you have
over the years we have a lot a lot
and that's an interesting point that it
doesn't feel like you've won oh no okay
so this is crazy I in my head
still feel like we're
tiny
genuinely I'm not even just saying that
to you like the concept of going public
and all of these things in my mind I go
to the office every day and I'm like
okay how are we gonna get off the ground
like literally I don't think you
understand I'm genuinely
locked in a place of we have so much
more to do and we have so much more
growth to be had that I feel like it's a
reset every day so I will say how is it
possible to be happy when you're
you're never there
but it's not that I'm never there in a
personal sense it's not like I'm like oh
I don't feel like
validate it's it's not that anymore it's
that there are still billions of people
around the world that have never heard
about Bumble and there are still
millions and millions and millions of
women around the world right now in bad
relationships
toxic relationships where they don't
understand that they should can and
eventually will go first in their life
they can leave a bad relationship they
can go into a good relationship there
are women as we speak you know very well
we're all watching this unfold it's
absolutely heartbreaking
just advocating to be able to have
simple freedoms
just wanting to have the freedom to
exist in their society as an equal
so when I go to the office every day and
saying okay how are we going to launch
we're 132 years away from gender parity
maybe 136 okay either way it's not great
and so that's where I feel like I don't
have enough time in this lifetime to
achieve what I want to achieve forget
the personal accolades I don't care
about that stuff I am I am personally on
a personal level now thank God it's
required a lot of
you know self-care therapy wonderful
husband beautiful to healthy children
thank you God I am happy now but I'm not
happy about where women are globally and
that I feel unfulfilled because until we
really look around us and say women are
not
in these toxic terrible relationships
and
living in an unequal playing field I've
got to go to work
I gotta like get back to the office and
that's how I feel
pursuing that goal comes somewhat at the
expense of yourself in some in some
degree right whether that's your you
know because life could be easier if you
just decided not to pursue that goal it
could be easier yeah I could probably be
drinking pina coladas kind of beef
somewhere right now
so and I always always think about this
you know the the pursuit of this of a
goal versus like you know
self-preservation and and taking care of
yourself and
you seem like someone that is somewhat
willing to sacrifice themselves to a
degree sacrifice something to fulfill a
goal that might even hurt yourself in
your own life in a sense of like
psychological harm or balance or you
know it's definitely sleep yeah no this
is this is probably the biggest uh this
is the This Is The Balancing Act we all
talk about right but
you can't do it all every single day why
not go to the beach you know why not go
and have a pina colada you want to go
have a pizza okay
um there's gotta be like a group therapy
for like why why why won't you go have a
pina colada on the beach
um
foreign
I don't know I just I feel very
passionate about what I'm doing
and when I stop feeling passionate I'll
go have a pina colada and then I'll go
do something different but this is
it feels like my life's work and I I try
to be a good mom and I try to be a good
wife and I try to be a good to myself
and take those times and I think
anyone that sits around tells you like
oh it's all about balance and I mean
maybe they're right maybe they've got
some secret that I don't know about
but my God I don't know I don't I don't
think any day is fully balanced right I
don't think any of us go to sleep every
night feeling like wow I just got a 10
out of 10 on every single category today
I think you just do your best and for me
I get joy out of
pushing
this brand forward I get joy out of the
women that come up to me and tell me
that they were in an abusive marriage
for 20 years and read a story about
Bumble and left their spouse and got on
Bumble and are happy in healthy
relationships like that's what this is
all about for me
it looked like that question made you a
bit emotional yeah I am emotional about
it because
I'm kind of doing this for my 17 year
old self also right I don't want another
generation of
me at 17. I don't want another
generation of that I don't want another
generation of young women that
felt unworthy and felt
lesser than and felt like they needed a
man to tell them what to do
and I just don't I don't want to see
that as this next wave of 17 year old so
I also don't want to see all these women
suffering from domestic and emotional
abuse across the world so you know
there's lots of ways and a lot of people
around the world that are doing a lot to
fix this
but I don't have those skill sets I
don't have you know maybe I don't know
how to do what they know how to do and I
know how to do this
so I feel like I better just lean in
while I can and plus I I'm definitely
old for the Gen Z people out there but
I'm 33 so I feel like you know I might
have
a little bit more on me somewhere
if you're old I'm old so I thought how
old are you I just turned 30. so wait
you're three years younger than me
that's like I just turned 30. it's like
five decades younger no it's not we're
in the same we're in the same school
well happy birthday whenever it was yeah
it was about a couple of weeks ago well
happy birthday yeah
that for me that answer really answers a
lot of questions because it shows where
the drive is coming from and that's the
reason why the Pina Coladas seem like a
lower priority than the mission
going back to the question which I kind
of took us off in a tangent away from
um about why you think Bumble won
um or was successful was able to break
through into that very small category of
dating apps or your dating sites where
there's really only like a handful of
real players
why why because I know you know I have
to say something I know that the other
dating apps because I was sometimes in
the room tried to launch dating apps of
themselves so they took their existing
Network they tried to launch a new
dating app into it and it didn't work
yeah I've seen it happen over and over
again I know Michelle
she's one of the people I used to work
with when we were doing the marketing at
Purdue oh really yeah yeah she's I I
think what she's done is awesome yeah I
love peanut it's it's great but but I
but I know it's not
easy and I know it's not chance and I
know it's not luck because I've seen I
can't tell you a social chain how many
times we had dating apps come to us and
say can you do our marketing maybe 200
times
there's 5 000 dating apps in the App
Store it's impossible it's impossible
it's impossible possible to start a new
one because of the network effects and
all of those things it's impossible
impossible
so why you
how you how
every other dating product until Bumble
had been solving for the wrong side of
the coin they've been thinking about men
that's all they woke up in the morning
and thought about how to make a dating
app good for guys and they had it
backwards
why are you solving for men when this is
all about what women need and what women
want no one was asking women you think
women want to get abused on the internet
think again like
find me a woman that enjoys being
harassed on a dating app not one
but for some reason that problem didn't
strike anyone as a problem
so
it's not that hard to say wait a second
this is a double-sided Marketplace
this product can't survive without women
yet we're exploiting and degrading women
on a lot of these products not naming
any names
what and so for me
it was all about taking that original
concept of Mercy a kind space for women
a safe space for women
and to Andre's push got to give him got
to give him some credit for being so
interested in dating right I was so
turned off of dating I wanted nothing to
do with dating when Andre was like oh
let's do a dating you know come be my
CMOS first of all I'm not for hire I'm
starting my own company I
must be founder and CEO of whatever I do
next I cannot work for someone I just I
have to be my own boss
and um
you know I got to give him a lot of
credit because he trusted that and he
said okay do whatever you want to do but
it just my one stipulation is it has to
be in dating because I know dating
and I want to get behind a dating
product so
when I was sitting there you know we
were
we had kind of agreed to okay we're
going to do this dating app what's it
going to be what about Mercy I wanted to
be Mercy I wanted to be about women and
I want to be women only I want safety
and kindness and accountability there's
no internet spaces for women nothing's
been built for women we have to do this
for women
and then it kind of just all clicked
and I sat there and within literally
minutes
it all just wrote itself I said wait a
second
I know the problem
women don't go first men do
men message as many women as they can
women are getting inundated they never
respond
the lack of response is causing a
rejection
and the rejection is triggering an
aggression and that aggression is now
translating into
harassment and this is why women are
being abused on the dating apps because
if only they would go first the man
wouldn't feel rejected
they'd feel empowered it would totally
calibrate this whole experience and I
said okay great I know what we're gonna
do
women have to talk first on this product
and they only have 24 hours to do it
I knew nobody else could conceptualize
the way I would explain it so I was like
thanks Cinderella the pumpkin and the
carriage and men can send one extend on
time a day to capture their attention if
they want to now we have to also call
out something this was back in 2014 in a
very heterosexual oriented dating app
experience
the landscape has evolved we have to be
inclusive to all and so of course we are
and of course we are currently as we
speak spending countless time and
putting all of our heart and soul into
how to make the experience better for a
non-binary for the trans Community for
anybody that identifies as a woman as
well right and so that's a big portion
of the future but
that was really how I would say we
became successful because of two things
woman making sure that we were solving
for women's real problems on the
internet
marketing to women so when I went back
to those sororities and fraternities
instead of going in with you know
whatever we had gone in at Tinder I went
in with things for women
I went in with items women wanted cute
yellow cookies like I understood that we
are going to build a cute brand not a
sexy brand
and that's what set us apart I wanted it
to feel warm and cozy and inviting and
soft and feminine and safe
and that's the beginning
and still the current through line of
bumble
what do you like as a leader
because leadership has evolved you know
over the last 10 20 years from like the
Steve Jobs days where you've got this
kind of tyrant that from what I've heard
so so hard to deal with that they put
him in his own building and only people
could we could work in that building if
they were really resilient I had all
these stories I spoke to was was didn't
tell me that was
um was the closest I've ever got to
Steve to Steve Jobs but leadership and
the concept of what a leader looks like
and how they behave and how they treat
people in a post-internet world where we
have the ability to speak up because we
can tweet and go our store and all of
these things leadership the leadership
has changed uh our perceptions of it how
they behave in a post-pandemic world
leaders are much more vulnerable
because I think a lot of them had to be
really vulnerable during the pandemic to
to guide their teams through what if I
asked your teams if I said you know
what's Whitney like as a leader what
would they say to me
um
I feel like I try I try and so you know
I'm sure I could be told otherwise
I try to
be empathetic and I try to think about
everyone around me probably to my
detriment honestly
um
I think it's probably done me more harm
than good over the years because I'm
trying to solve for every single person
in the room that maybe it doesn't solve
anything sometimes
um but I really I try to just be the
brand we are externally internally
um it's hard you know there's
so many conflicting needs as a business
you have a marketing and brand team that
when I do one thing you have a technical
team that needs to do another you have
IPO teams that have to do another and so
you end up being this conductor of a
very
um
um loud Orchestra and I try to create
harmony with people but
um I don't know I I guess I wouldn't say
I follow any I don't read leadership
books I don't like take leadership
courses maybe that's something I should
do I don't know but I just lead with my
gut I just do what feels right I try to
do the right thing I try to listen and
hear what people are saying and I try to
listen to other people too so if one
person calls me and says
X Y or Z I try to call the other person
and say what's your version of this
before I
jump to a conclusion
um I really try to have compassion for
where everybody's coming from but it's
tough and then I also have to put my
head down and say okay no sometimes this
is just how it's going to go right
because I feel like I can see certain
things that maybe
aren't present to everyone in the dating
space because I've been in this thing
for a decade now and I feel like I
understand the nuances of it very well
so I don't know I don't know what they
would say you talked about creating
Harmony amongst the orchestra which I
feel like is the perfect example of the
role of a CEO but a role of the CEO of a
public company becomes even more
difficult because then you have even
more conflicting
um expectations when you're that person
that's trying to create a Harmony
in all of this Orchestra
keep everybody happy
meet all the needs
how do you create Harmony within
yourself
so I personally
have
beliefs that you know there's something
bigger than what we're dealing with
every day right like I tried to zoom out
zoom out into something that we can't
even see right there's obviously
influences of the universe that none of
us know about you and I cannot sit here
and say that we know every corner of why
we exist and what what's going to happen
tomorrow and so I try to just trust the
process
I try to laugh Andre was always really
good at that he would just laugh in
really stressful situations and I
learned that from him it's just like
have a laugh he'll be okay and also to
realize that we are just a blip on the
radar like this is going to be like
if we're lucky like Bumble will be like
a half page in a book one day at the
hundreds of years from now like it's
just not that big of a deal the daily
dramas and the nuances of everything and
so I tried to just zoom out like is this
really going to still matter this one
moment in interpersonal Dynamics or this
one moment in
um a a failed launch or whatever it
might be is this really going to matter
in five years is this gonna matter in
five months and I really try to do that
exercise of like how big of a deal is
this before
I allow it to disrupt my Harmony
does that make sense I don't know if
that made any sense it does make sense
it does make sense
um I was reading things about your your
sort of sleep work routine and you
sounded a lot like me
I'm the type of person that has an a
fairly unhealthy relationship with my
phone throughout through throughout the
early hours of the morning especially
especially when I was running the
company especially when I was at Social
chain still
um I'd wake up in the middle of the
night I was probably I was worried too
too often when we couldn't make payroll
and I knew it was payday in a week I'd
be riddled with little sort of slithers
of anxiety when we spoke to
um I think it's Robbie oh yeah he's
great Robbie and your team
Robbie said she makes no pretense of
being always strong and is openly
vulnerable with the team
where you might walk into the office one
day and let them know that you've been
struggling with something might you
might be anxious or struggling with
anxiety that day and encourage your
other team members if they're feeling
the same way to take the time that they
need
well that's really nice of him but yeah
I mean vulnerability is
it has to be authentic I've watched so
many people the last few years ride this
vulnerability Trend and I'm like that's
not real vulnerable like vulnerability
can't be a scapegoat or an exit or a
crutch for me
I don't know I just I just tell the
truth if I'm having postpartum
depression back when after my first baby
I would just say that to my all hands
because that was the truth and why would
I be anything other than truthful if I
want to lead a company that tells the
truth and I want to run a business that
instills behaviors that are truthful and
and healthy and and better like why
would I want to operate in any way
that's disingenuous to that so I just
get up and just try to tell the truth
um convention would say well that's not
your leaders are strong and then that
they don't they don't have any problems
and they they're always tough and they
you know they you know so what if and
this is honestly what I used to worry
about I used to think well if I if I'm
truly honest that that things affect me
too my team are going to think I'm weak
and then I can't lead them and that's
the kind of narrative that ran out in my
head
yeah
but and I get that
but the reality is everyone's everyone's
feeling something
and I'm in a connection business how can
I run a connection company if I can't
connect
and the only way you can connect is
through vulnerability it's the only way
to connect with anyone I'm being very
vulnerable with you right now because
we're sitting here connecting so I might
as well you know I could sit here and be
like well it's a business book I read
you know there's this theory of like you
know this many hours a day do this and
like that's just
not my vibe we sit here in 10 years time
and we say that that was a really
successful 10 years for Bumble what
would have happened in those 10 years
we would have
built world-class features that were
industry changing for safety and Trust
on the internet we would have become the
safest platform for women not only to
date but to find any trusted contact
that they need a mentor a mentee a
babysitter a friend somebody that has
the same illness as them as rare as it
might be somebody who is struggling with
any type of Mental Health crisis the
platform to find anyone on a trusted
safe wavelength and we would have also
gone and created a suite of laws to
actually build real legislature around
the gaps that exist for physical and
digital accountability as it pertains to
women's well-being and we would have
scaled globally to every corner of the
Earth where
women need us the most and we would be a
trusted product for them to
find their innate strength to quite
literally make the first move out of
something bad and into something good
and we would have built a brand that
showed everybody that you can
have Mission and profit live under the
same roof and you can be a Kinder
connected company
irrespective of how everybody else has
done it before
so that's what I would hope for
thank you
understanding your understanding you and
understanding what's driving you I would
certainly bet on that becoming a reality
um and I think that's the most that's
really you know of all the the business
success the marketing Brilliance and all
of the things that you've done and the
resilience and the getting back up and
all of those things that in and of
themselves you kind of we describe them
in a couple of minutes but I but any
human that struggled and been rejected
and had you know been mischaracterized
knows that those aren't small things so
for many people even one of those things
is entirely fatal but there's clearly
this unbelievable resilience in you
because he said well where does that you
know I think I think you said it where I
think you said it on a podcast one time
where you said it doesn't matter if you
lose your confidence you still have your
drive and I really pondered that when
you said that I thought is that true
because the thing is lose your
confidence yourself well you do you
still have the drive whether you have
the the the belief that comes from
confidence that you can have it but you
still have that drive and that's exactly
what I've
I've learned from you today which is
that unshakable bigger than myself a
mission bigger than me drive which is
driving you and your company and that's
why I think you're an unbelievable
inspiration but Bumble is an
unbelievable bet on the future a future
which I think is inevitable in the
future that is necessary so thank you
for your time today it's a huge honestly
when I say it's a huge honor I mean it's
a huge honor I feel the same way about
you so thank you for having me
um today we have a closing tradition on
the podcast where the last guest asks a
question for the next guest they don't
know who they're leaving it for
so they just leave it in the diary I
open it and I get to read it now
um the question they left for you not
knowing it was you was what is the last
belief you would relinquish
it's an interesting question like what
would I let go of what belief do I have
like what is there a belief I have that
I would let go of
yeah so I hear me shouldn't give away
who it is he means like what's the it's
basically what's the most important
belief to you what's the last belief
that you would give up
oh um the last belief that I would give
up is that people
are inherently good
somewhere deep down that rejection and
insecurity and lack of communication
Drive cruelty and
that I'm not going to give up on a world
where we can actually connect good
people together because I think there's
a lot of
a lot of good people out there that just
need a Kinder way to connect
amen
thank you Whitney thank you
quick one some of you may know we've got
a brand new sponsor for this podcast
it's American Express and this
partnership still blows my mind as I'm
an avid user of American Express so with
that being said let me tell you about
their new business Platinum Card
benefits firstly new card members will
receive a 200 pound annual Travel credit
to be spent when you spend at American
Express Travel online on flights hotels
and car rentals secondly if you need
help with your expenses then American
Express business cards offer Amex
expense which is simply a brand new and
free expenses Management Service for its
business platinum card holders where you
just need to upload your receipts and
invoices as you go this streamlined
system can be integrated with your
accounting software you will also be
able to Monitor and generate expense
reports straight through Amex expense
platform a total Game Changer and it
saved me so much time and lastly as an
American Express business Platinum Card
member you have access to a wide variety
of American Express offers including
digital subscription to the times the
Sunday Times worth 3 300 pounds so if
you'd like to find out how you can get
your hands on your new American Express
business card then search American
Express business platinum card to find
out more quick one from our longest
standing sponsor hero I I can't tell you
over the last and say over the last
really it's been about two and a half
years it was really um post pandemic how
much my health has become such a huge
priority in my life and I have this
laser laser focused on what I'm putting
into my body it's funny because as you
get older you can start to feel the
things you're putting into your body
more and more and more
um and if I if I put something into my
body especially things like gluten if I
put those things in my body I feel them
tremendously the next day my energy
levels my sleep and everything in
between huel has been probably the most
important partner in my health Journey
because
I've been in the boardrooms I've been to
their offices
tens and tens and tens and tens of times
I've seen how they make their decisions
on nutrition and I trust it most of my
team that are in this room with me
consume it and get the benefits of it
too so if you haven't already tried your
do so
thank you